fragilisée mais loin d'être vaincu nikol
pashinian en témoignent les milliers de
personnes venues se rassembler ici pour
apporter leur soutien au premier
ministre arménien à nikol pashinian
avait demandé à tous ses partisans de se
réunir à 18h30 heure locale
ici place de la république afin de
démontrer à l'opposition que le soutien
populaire est toujours de son côté
mission accomplie pour le premier
ministre arménien une mobilisation qui
était au rendez-vous mais également un
pas en avant vers l'opposition puisqu'il
a accepté des élections législatives
anticipées pour je cite laisser une
chance à l'opposition
c'est ce qu'il a déclaré lors de son
discours écoutez je tiens à m'excuser
auprès de tout le monde de tous les
citoyens de tous les arméniens de la
diaspora de tous les citoyens du haut
karabagh pour mes erreurs mais j'ai
beaucoup réfléchi
ou est-ce que je m'étais trompé de tels
cas peuvent être soulevées puis il est
plus important de se demander pourquoi
l'équipe gouvernementale s'est trompé
ironiquement l'une des principales
raisons de nos serveurs était notre
popularité montante le gouvernement
le président arménien armen sarkissian
souvenez-vous avait refusé la demande de
révocation du chef d'état-major demande
au père et à part le premier ministre
arménien mais là aussi à des raisons
d'espérer un puisque le conseil national
de sécurité d'arménie a demandé au
président à d'approuver cette motion du
coup l'opposition se retrouve face à un
dilemme à mai à la mobilisation était
également au rendez-vous en devant le
parlement où plusieurs milliers de
personnes étaient également réunis
depuis jeudi dernier quotidiennement de
jour comme de nuit
des manifestants anti-pape chillan se
rassemblent afin de réclamer le départ
du premier ministre arménien considéré
comme responsable de la défaite
militaire dans le haut karabagh une
défaite militaire vécue comme une
véritable humiliation nationale pour la
plupart de ces manifestants et coûté
nicole pas de signal est un traître
il nous a trahis il a trahi son peuple
la république d'arménie la république
d'arsac nos terres nos jeunes gars qui
sont morts là bas qui jusqu'à présent
sont portées disparues les prisonniers
il avait le devoir de s'occuper de ces
questions mais il ne l'a pas fait on ne
peut rien faire à erevan sur cette terre
parce qu'il n'ya pas de travail
quand je travaillais si quelqu'un me
disait qu'il n'avait pas de travail je
pouvais lui en trouver en une heure à
noter que malgré la proximité à des deux
rassemblements pro et anti opa chine jan
aucun débordement à signaler un
important dispositif de sécurité avait
été mis en place tout autour de cette
place de la république mais également
tout autour du parlement pour éviter des
oppositions entre anti-opa xi'an et pro
pas xi'an et éviter à des scènes
similaires à celles qu'on avait pu voir
au début du soulèvement populaire en
tout cas l'opposition compte maintenir
sa présence devant le parlement malgré à
ce pas en avant a fait part à nicolas
pas xi'an reste à savoir pour combien de
temps